- [Narrator] Though I'm
interested in finding
the relationship between
people's height in inches
and their weight in pounds.
And so I'm randomly
sampling a bunch of people
measuring their heights,
measuring their weight
and then for each person
I'm plotting a point
that represents their height
and weight combination.
So for example let's say I measure someone
who is 60 inches tall, that'll
be about five feet tall
and they weigh 100 pounds.
And so I'd go to 60 inches
and then 100 pounds.
Right over there so that
point right over there
is the point 60 comma, 60 comma, 100.
One way to think about
it, height we could say
is being measured on our
X axis or plotted along
our X axis and then
weight along our Y axis.
And though this point from
this person is the 0.60, 100
representing 60 inches, 100 pounds.
And so so I've done it
for one, two, three, four
five, six, seven, eight, nine
people and I could keep going
but even with this I could say, well look,
it looks like there's a roughly
linear relationship here.
It looks like it's positive,
that generally speaking
as height increases so does weight.
Maybe I could try to put a line that can
approximate this trend.
Let me try to do that
so this is my line tool.
I could think about a bunch of lines.
Something like this
seems like it would be,
you'd be, most of the
data is below the line
so that seems like it's not right.
I could do something like,
I could do something like this
but that doesn't seem like a good fit.
Most the data seems to be above the line.
And so once again I'm
just eyeballing it here,
in the future you will learn
better methods of finding
a better fit.
But that's something like this
and I'm just eyeballing it
looks about right.
So that line, you could view
this as a regression line.
We could view this as y equals mx plus b.
Where we would have to
figure out the slope
and the Y intercept and
we could figure it out
based on what I just drew or
we could even think of this
as weight.
Weight is equal to our slope times height.
Times height plus whatever
our Y intercept is,
if you think of the vertical
axis as the weight axis
you could think of it as
your weight intercept.
But either way this is
the model that I'm just
through eyeballing, this
is my regression line.
Something that I'm trying
to fit to these points.
But clearly it can't go through,
one line won't be able to
go to all of these points.
There's going to be for
each point some difference
or not for all of them
but for many of them,
some difference between the
actual and what would have been
predicted by the line.
And that idea, the difference
between the actual four point
and what would have been
predicted, given say the height
that is called a residual.
Gonna write that down.
The A residual for each
of these data points.
And so for example if
I call this right here,
if I call that point one,
the residual for point one.
Is going to be well, for our variable,
for our height variable 60 inches.
The actual here is 100 pounds.
From that we would subtract
what would be predicted.
So what would be predicted
is right over here.
I could just substitute
60 into this equation
so it would be M times 60 plus b.
So I could write it as M,
maybe let me write it
this way, 60 M plus B.
Once again I would just take the 60 pounds
and put it into my model here and say,
well what weight would
that have predicted.
And I can even, just for the
sake of having a number here.
I can look, I can, let
me get my line tool out.
And try to get a straight
line from that point.
So from this point let
me get a straight line.
So that doesn't look quite straight,
okay a little bit, okay.
Okay so looks like it's about 150 pounds.
So my model would have
predicted 150 pounds.
So the residual here is going
to be equal to negative 50.
So a negative residual is when your actual
is below your predicted.
So this right over here.
This is our one, it is
a negative residual.
If you had, if you tried to find,
let's say this residual right
over here, for this point.
This r2, this would be a positive residual
because the actual is larger
than what would have
actually been predicted.
And so a residual is good for saying,
well how good does your
line, does your regression,
does your model fit a given data point
or how does a given data
point compare to that.
What you probably want
to do is think about
some combination of all the residuals
and try to minimize it.
Now you might say, well
why don't I just add up
all the residuals and
try to minimize that.
But that gets tricky
because some are positive
and some are negative and
so a big negative residual
could counterbalance the
big positive residual
and it would look, it would add up to zero
and then it look like there's no residual
so you could just add
up the absolute values.
So you could say, well
let me just take the sum
of all of the residual,
of the absolute value
of all the residuals.
And then let me change M and B for my line
to minimize this and
that would be a technique
of trying to create a regression line.
But another way to do
it and this is actually
the most typical way that
you will see in statistics
is that people take the sum of the squares
of the residuals.
The sum of the squares and
when you square something
whether it's negative or positive,
it's going to be a positive
so it takes care of that issue
of negatives and positives
canceling out with each other.
And when you square a number,
things with large residuals
are gonna become even
larger, relatively speaking.
You know, if you square
a large, you know one is,
if you think about this way,
let me put regular numbers,
one, two, three, four.
These are all one apart from each other
but if I were to square
them, one, four, nine, 16,
they get further and further apart
and so something, the
larger the residual is
when you square it,
when the sum of squares
is going to represent a
bigger proportion of the sum.
And so what we'll see in future videos
is that there is a technique called
least squares regression.
Least squares regression.
Where you can find an M and
a B for a given set of data
so it minimizes the sum of
the squares of the residual.
And that's valuable and the
reason why this is used most
is it really tries to take in account
things that are significant outliers.
Things that sit from pretty
far away from the model,
something like this is going to really,
with a least squares regression.
It's going to try to be minimized
or it's going to be weighted
a little bit heavier
because when you square it becomes
even a bigger factor in this.
But this is just a
conceptual introduction.
In future videos we'll do
things like calculate residuals.
And we'll actually derive the formula
for how do you figure out
an M and a B for a line
that actually minimizes
the sum of the squares
of the residuals.